the central dogma is one of biology's
most fundamental principles it states
that dna provides the instructions to
make rna which in turn directs the
production of proteins
here we'll be focusing on the second
part of this process where rna guides
the creation of proteins also known as
translations
rna is similar to its better known
cousin dna except for one nucleotide
base
which are the chemical units that make
up both dna and rna
rna uses the nucleotide uracil instead
of thymine which is found in dna
rna is also usually single stranded
unlike dna which is normally double
stranded
a specific type of rna called messenger
rna or mrna is responsible for providing
instructions to make proteins
a group of three rna bases known as a
codon encode for specific amino acids
and multiple amino acids strung together
make a protein
a triplet makes mathematical sense
because it's the smallest number of
bases that can produce enough possible
combinations
or 64 to be exact to code for all 20
amino acids as well as codons that
signal for translation to stop
as 64 codons more than covers the 20
amino acids the redundancy in the
genetic code means that anywhere from
one to six codons will encode for a
specific amino acid
and this redundancy is important among
other things it provides an extra layer
of safety in case the wrong nucleotide
base is placed in a particular location
which helps ensure that less mistakes
are made during the translation process
along the bottom here are the amino
acids shown in their simple single
letter form
the actual process of translation occurs
through the action of a huge protein rna
complex called the ribosome which reads
codons one by one and incorporates the
appropriate amino acid at the beginning
of every mrna is a start codon formed by
the bases aug which codes for the amino
acid methionine and tells the ribosome
where to start translating
in order to translate a codon into an
amino acid another kind of rna called a
transfer rna or trna binds an amino acid
on one end and matches up with the
corresponding codon from the mrna on the
other end
when the trna brings the amino acid that
matches the next codon in the mrna the
amino acid attaches to the previous one
which starts the growing chain of amino
acids
the process of attaching the amino acid
to the previous one in the chain
disconnects the trna from the amino acid
and the naked trna leaves the ribosome
and the process continues
this process continues until the
ribosome hits one of the three stop
codons which signals the ribosome that
it should stop
once translating
stop codon is reached the resulting
amino acid chain is released from the
ribosome and usually transported through
organelles known as the endoplasmic
reticulum and the golgi apparatus
these organelles help fold the amino
acid chain into the correct shape as
well as complete any additional
modifications needed to form a complete
and functional protein
meanwhile the ribosomes are reused to
take part in the translation of other
mrna molecules
this elegant complex process is the
basis of every single cellular function
in our bodies and helps ensure
everything runs according to our
molecular instruction code our dna
you